rolling all right guys we're out here in
the beautiful Santa Monica Mountains
this is Malibu Creek State Park and this
is the actual site where they filmed the
television show mash is called the mash
christian Isaacson who flew down from
Portland to do the podcast he is a epic
ultra endurance athlete this guy was a
tough finisher and ultra man this past
year and did epic five the year after I
did it he did it in five days and he
came down all different kinds of things
his service work in Kenya through the
Amina project what it's like to be a dad
and a husband
kind of a journey that he's taken to get
where he is now and the rock and roll
rock n roll the crushed rock and roll
dream a consistent theme in the rich
roll pockets training one dream the
dream of rock and roll for the dream of
Ultron the wrong dream for the right
thing so yeah we talked for and we could
have talked for three hours on epic saga
whoa easy so cool so blessing and a gift
to have him down here to chat with us
we'll be bringing you that episode soon
for the date that we're going to release
the episode look down below here at the
bottom of the YouTube pay no perfidy
goal it's gonna be a good one if you
want to know more about this guy go to
his website it is Christian Isaacson
calm yep on Twitter Luke 9:22 out and
then Instagram is Luke nine to zero
right
all that stuff is all good I know where
to find me
which girl calm
so alright come on bus